our next speaker are our own Walter yets
who's associate professor over here in
the department of ecology and
evolutionary biology also has close ties
around this school as well and Walter is
going to be speaking on the map of Life
Project right thanks a lot dave and
thanks everybody for coming and thanks
to the speaker's early this afternoon
and John for really brilliant overview
and and with those questions we had
actually just a minute ago we actually
have a nice segue into what I'm trying
to talk about here I'll be jumping
straight into a specific project that's
certainly not small in scope but it's
narrower than some of what we've heard
this afternoon I think it's become clear
really neat leaf from Jonathan Hector's
talk that there is a need for a detailed
spatial biodiversity and knowledge
remember those maps and the question we
just had earlier those were very broad
blobs in the world and actually all of
these different organizations we're
trying to get at a different aspect of
beta risky but all of them had
incomplete knowledge so they were saying
well roughly here are endemic or
threatened species of this or that or
here are roughly endangered ecosystems
but ultimately what they were really all
wanted would have liked to have is
actually detailed biodiversity data that
they would then of course link to other
socio-economic variables that they were
interested in as an organization but
it's mostly that lack of that sort of
data that has caused these regions
including the ecoregions with which have
been really important in conservation
prioritization at least at the very
broad skill and and helping taking the
next steps it's the lack of knowledge
that has held us back in many ways the
other point just connecting to previous
speakers is that we do need the global
perspective here it became clear from
the Ebert analysis even faux focused on
the u.s. we saw that birds are moving in
and out of the US every year and we saw
from the encyclopedia of life that are
from an educational perspective
and from some of the memo prioritization
analyses conservation privacy analysis
that herodotus eval showed us or Ben
Collins work that we need to take a
global perspective if we want to do
successful conservation pride as a shin
and indeed successfully want to answer
some of the still important than
remaining questions that are basic in
biodiversity science now what I'm going
to talk about is a project an initiative
that's very young it's only a year and a
half two years old so we are by far not
as advanced and and it's stunning and
important recognized as the encyclopedia
of life is or several of the other
projects we've heard about today but we
are trying to sort of focus on one
specific aspect and try come in from a
scientist perspective and try and get
that right and bring the right people
together both on the NGO geo as well as
the science world to get that done and
just trying to tell you a little bit
about that what going so much into my
own research but into explaining to you
that larger web-based infrastructure
that dynamic infrastructure that
Jonathan was was sort of alluding to
that the importance of being dynamic and
being able to respond quickly as new
data comes in and as environment changes
that sort of infrastructure we're trying
to put together with the map of life let
me start out with this image here it's
based on NASA satellites it's a global
land cover classification down at a
resolution of 500 meters we have a
reasonably good understanding of the
global land cover thanks to other remote
sensing products we have an
understanding of the global topography
at about 90 meters or even 30 meters so
incredibly detailed data at the global
scale all the way from the tropics to
the high latitudes data that's very very
scientifically accurate and usable and
that's coming about has been coming up
about over the last 10 years or so here
this Steve mentioned important temporal
dimension we have also an incredibly
detailed temporal picture here of how
land cover or here the greenness of
vegetation changes week by week every
day we're getting this data in so and
it's an incredible amount of data it's
this big data that's coming in on a
daily basis that actually provides
extremely detailed information about
this planet now putting this together
this makes us realize that as far as
environment is concerned climate
topography we are now at a point where
we have an extremely detailed
understanding of our planet at a scale
or a grain size a pixel size of down to
as I said 90 meters with regards to bog
raphy globally with as far as climate is
concerned can extract temperature and
rainfall information out of many of
these satellite products down to a
kilometer 500 meters land cover 500
meters evening projected land cover some
of those models sort of taking climate
change projections and then connecting
them in the vegetation projecting into
the future even those models are getting
down to a 50 kilometer detail now and of
course and then no need to mention that
I understanding of where humans are and
what they do is also a spatially very
detailed and you saw some of those maps
earlier bye bye John so what's really
the question then is where are we with
our species distribution data with our
biodiversity knowledge clearly we seem
not to be at this fine grain otherwise
we wouldn't have such blobby maps of the
world sort of where our important areas
for conservation so what is our global
biodiversity knowledge well there is the
global biodiversity information facility
a really important global organization
that's pulling together point data
mostly from all sorts of collections
particularly museums around the world
but increasingly some other data sources
a point data and this is the map of the
world according to
if the millions of records in here but
you see it's geographically highly
biased and we saw a similar biased map
earlier from from ebert because we're
people or even birders are is not
necessarily always we're actually by the
whiskey's or it doesn't really cover the
world evenly so we're getting a very
geographically biased data from that and
then here a little analysis that cars
Meyer is there any audience and others
and may have done that is digging a
little deeper here and actually trying
to do some some more quantitative
understanding of what sort of bias or
type of knowledge we're actually talking
about here with chiba 'the gb feels
really like the global effort and
pulling together point data distribution
data as it's coming from museums mostly
and it's been going on for ten years or
longer and this is what we have entry
biff currently we have certainly
millions of records but as you see the
richness of species according to these
records here over a hundred kilometer
raster is well looks like this and in
many parts of the world this looks like
like a good coverage but when you relate
relate sorry we're looking here at the
richness up here is simply the number of
of cheap if records so the number of
points and you see these biases and
here's the richness map and yes we get
the great gradients that we see sort of
in some parts of the world certainly
more species here in southwestern
Australia then inland etc but there is
very barely any concordance with the
expert knowledge about the species
richness of those two groups so the
world according to cheap if the richness
of the world is very very little
resemblance with the the actual species
richness because for those two groups we
actually have expert maps that allow us
to analyze this at 100 kilometers
resolution and I come back to that so in
this next analysis we asked the question
how much would you have to sort of dumb
down or corson our gb point record to
actually get to a full coverage so
to to really capture all the species
occurring in the region and even as you
go out to about eight hundred eighty
kilometers in many parts of the world
we're still only capturing up to date
about thirty to fifty percent of the
species so only here in in of course
north america and europe and parts of
australia this point data gives us a
proper impression of biodiversity of the
species richness but it does only so at
about 800 kilometers of 900 kilometers
and that's not the grain at which you
can understand biological mechanisms and
it's also not the grain at which you can
do practical conservation and it's
important to realize that you can do
some things with this point data but
there are limits to what you can do so
many of you may have heard about this
idea of environmental niche modeling
going back to green nail who sort of
introduced as about 100 years ago in
California here the California fresh of
the species which she first applied that
general idea that you can connect
distribution points to quantify an
environmental niche sort of the
multivariate space in which the species
is sitting sort of the climate climatic
niche and nowadays we can do that in a
really technically sophisticated way
with all sorts of GIS layers connect
that up with this sort of point data we
have and we can then quantify this
niches of this climatic envelope in
which the species is sitting but a fact
is that in many cases and I will show a
few examples later the point date of you
have so where people are running around
there were people previously shot some
specimen and put them in a museum is not
necessarily where species actually
occurs so usually we have a very biased
impression of the true distribution of a
species and in fact the niche of the
species may be looking like this and
that's really important when you try to
then to climate change projections and
that's a very popular thing to do these
days sort of try to project the niche of
a species into the future where made be
in the future or what at least all the
suitable areas in the future for certain
species if you get this if you don't get
this right that's sampling if it's not
representative you're also not getting
that right and that's a really sober
lesson for conservation science in
face of climate change now expert range
maps are a totally different type of
species distribution information in for
some groups of species especially
vertebrates but increasingly also other
groups butterflies beetles and so on
plant groups we we have pretty good
expert knowledge so that's partly built
on points but actually mostly often on
true expert field knowledge and
understanding of species habitats that
then looks like this and we've done some
various analyses on that type of data to
and I'll spare you the details see I'm
just going to show you one example that
kind of tells the whole story here's the
Congo peacock and this is still at this
point in time our understanding of the
global distribution of that species this
is the only peacock in Africa it's kind
of its own genus and own very separate
group it's not a small species and it's
really really a special bird that's
human by the piracy knowledge about that
species and when you then relate that to
other types of data you find out well
it's roughly a curated about a hundred
kilometer per hundred kilometer
resolution I mean I spent a lot of time
trying to track down that species right
here in the middle and actually didn't
find it that even in a month and a half
so it's even within those blogs you have
many holes where the species doesn't
occur and that then translating it to
this idea of about a accurate at about a
hundred kilometer grain right you have a
lot of folds oops false presences in
this map as we say now contrast this
with our knowledge of the logging
concessions in this region right or
what's happening in this part of the
world as soon as it will more and more
stabilized very pretty much have an idea
of what places are going to go to
plantations and so on and we still don't
quite now where this peacock occurs and
in which a few reserves and they're also
where exactly it is actually sitting and
will be protected in the future so I
said about a hundred kilometer accuracy
in expert maps and that's what this era
here is referring to so though for
vertebrates for terrestrial vertebrates
we can bring it down to about
here for all vertebrates we have a
coronal data that John talked about
earlier so on average those places are
200 to 300 to 400 kilometers across
that's our knowledge of that for some
groups we have 100 kilometer data for
some very few species the global range
would be covered through a standardized
survey effort that is whatever 50
kilometer resolution or so on but those
would be species are restricted to kono
South Africa corner of Europe or a
corner of the United States all other
species would be sitting over here and
that's the number of species we're
talking about so there's a huge
knowledge gap now what map of life tries
to do is to overcome that knowledge gap
by integrating different types of
distribution data now regional
checklists here for example that will be
your ecoregion list so for every one of
those 800 ecoregions in the world there
would be a species list and now the
grain of that sort of list is very
coarse but then it has barely any bias
so that's a good thing its global
coverage that's great how is every
species in a certain group but then you
have a high false presence rate so not
within every corner of an eco region you
will actually find that species right so
that's why we overestimating the places
where species are actually occur and
that's why that data has such
limitations but if we bring this
together with these point records we may
be able to overcome of some of that
because they're false positive rate is
very low on the other hand they are
biased as I just pointed out right so
those cheap if points are geographically
very biased now there are many other
types of data that come in here but just
this just as an overview and as part of
a larger group of people and in
particular make OPI Rob gorelick who is
in the audience also and will be
speaking tomorrow we've pulled together
this initiative of a map of life and
infrastructure for integrating advancing
and apply and applying global species
distribution knowledge the idea is here
to put together an online dynamic
workbench for documenting annotating
integrating validating advancing and
ultimately analyzing the
sources of global biodiversity
distribution knowledge and this is how
is supposed to work and this is how
we've started it out there are these
different types of data and I'm just
mentioning a few here in this example
and they come from a variety of
different sources and here's Chi beef of
course which is an important aggregator
of point data but so are many other
places there is tracking point data
there are many checklist compilations
they are governmental and
non-governmental organizations and
museums pulling data sets together and
if we were to mobilize that data and
much of it is already mobilized but
there is more to be done and bring it
together in one place on the web where
we can display it then at very first
step at least we can do editing and
quality control and quality control is a
really important step here we'll see
that in just a moment and we can crowd
source if you will feedback we can set
up a spatially explicit wiki that helps
with the quality control and provides
feedback on some of this and of course
the point of incentivizing came up
earlier that's of course really
important but by adding further down the
road here additional services we hope to
really facilitate the mobilization now
I'll be giving you a little
demonstration in just a moment but here
are some of the initial ideas that are
really really important some of which
already implemented that of course we
need to be able to filter data flag data
should be able to upload own data sets
we are connecting with various citizen
science initiatives such as Ebert and
others to allow the direct well a direct
connection or for other groups besides
birds ultimately the direct upload of
observations and particularly scientists
datasets that's a really untapped
resource that we want to mobilize here
to really help fill some of the gaps
that of course or critical and then
offer various services down the road so
more generally the idea here is that we
address some of the key
storage metadata query user feedback
quality control visualization and
modeling challenges that our kind of
common to all spatial biodiversity
projects so that's really important to
understand that of course museums or
small regional NGOs or people interested
a certain group of species have sort of
started to do some of this and throw
data up in the web but the problem of
that is that is first of all a lot of
duplication of effort and second data
often get stuck in in silos in sort of
separate containers and it doesn't come
together to really facilitate that
integration and that cross fostering
that brings together that problematic
blob map expert map with a problematic
point data set to have those data sets
cross inform each other and put it out
to the larger world to provide feedback
and quality control now it will now
attempt something that's very risky and
that is a live demo and our lead
programmer is somewhere in the ordinary
may actually have run out just in case
this is not working but looks good so
far we are on the map of live website
here in just a quick search for example
for a species called the Hoopoe a really
beautiful bird restricted to Europe and
this is first of all just a demo website
that I'm showing you right now but for
birds and for certain parts of the world
we already have a pretty neat set of
data sets ingested and in there or
dynamically linked and you see if we
compute the species we get a whole set
off we get like 15 or or 20 different
data sources that are sitting different
parts of the world and T beef is one of
them but only one of them that are
coming together here we can click map
selected layers and you see here the
words world is filling up note there's
some hoopoe in the ocean over here
that's the sort of data you sometimes
get with the large aggregators such as
such as cheap if we're there are still
problems with quality control but
bringing these different different types
of data together we were able to
actually address some of that
me move this away so here is the
specious it's a it's a migratory bird
but that also breeds the breeds in
Europe and Asia but also in Africa and
the points that you're seeing here those
are mostly points coming from Chiba and
could spend some time on this I could
click on these points and you would get
detailed information where they come
from I'm sure there are some ebert
points in there to actually we would
find that they're sitting over on the
computer in Cornell what you also see
pho is that the true distribution of the
species and those blob maps here give
you actually a good impression of the
large extent of that species is only
very in a very limited way covered by
pointed of course a lot of observations
here in Europe and a lot of observation
Co very rare for migrants that sort of
make it into Scandinavia but actually
not so representative for the species
but a lot of holes in it too and you see
two maps here by the ways one is matt
from my own lab and another one is the
IUCN map and they're kind of similar
hear those blob maps let me just zoom in
here to see show you another detail
going into this part of the world you
see these datasets pop up here these are
atlases so survey organized survey
efforts that have been done in this
region that also recorded for these
pixel that species and those are cells
that are 25 kilometer or 50 kilometer in
grain size so for that part of the world
we actually have a much more detailed
understanding of the species now if you
move up here to the higher latitudes we
are lacking such at least here's of in
Asia southern Asia we are lacking that
sort of survey data if we lacking points
now hearing grey you see the ecoregion
map because that's one large ecoregion
here and the species is recorded for the
ecoregion but that ecoregion data of
clearly over estimates despite the
distribution of that species this is the
expert range so it reaches in here
actually I saw this pieces over here at
some point and it is in some of those
wetter areas but it certainly isn't in
those really dry parts so that's where
you see how some of the coarser datasets
are clearly limited now
here is another example of a species the
ground hornbill and here let me just
point out another type of data these are
local inventories these are reserved
checklists where the species was
recorded and again here only from this
region atlas data and a few point data
sets but otherwise with just point data
we would be completely misunderstanding
that species with ecoregion data that
gray part part here we'd be
overestimating the range of the species
and now next step would be to allow
people to give feedback and allow range
edits here and then voting on that
inaccurate Oriole system that deals with
that now one final click demonstration
here we have a species list tool that if
I click button here and actually we can
go to here and this is something that
Ebert and also a few other sites could
do I think for birds in North America at
least this has been done we can click on
a point of the world and get a species
list back for birds in this case you can
download that list you can do other
things but let's go to different parts
of the world and that's really the
important thing here that we're trying
to do an infrastructure that works
globally and that really tries to
overcome that that a symmetry that we
usually see in our knowledge and also in
educationally what's available in the
tropics compared to the high latitude so
we can go to this part of Brazil and you
see that circle they are we're now
clearing the species occurring in that
circle so within 50 kilometers of that
location and you get a list emit can
drill deeper here and for example this
is information that's coming from
Wikipedia in the encyclopedia of life we
could click on this page and get taken
to that species and learn more about it
so this is connecting back to Eric matas
talked earlier about encyclopedia of
life we can look at the images of the
species there so you can actually learn
get an impression of the
versity view of the visual diversity by
looking at those images can learn about
the phret status of the species of which
proportion of species is threatened or
not and you can download the list that
list let's go to a different part of the
world and let's actually go to go for a
different group let's go for amphibians
we can do this for amphibians for North
America and fishes and reptile and
reptiles and for mammals and birds and
here only 11 species of amphibians found
here here are the images for them there
are several of them that are near
threatened and you can do that in any
part of the world and of course there
are many educational use cases here and
even scientific use cases if you want to
find out what other species may occur
around you and then we are sort of
hoping to develop over the next half
year an iphone app of course that would
allow you to lift the GPS location of
your of your phone get that list and the
images and perhaps even a rough
identification guide and we're talking
with you well to perhaps partner up on
some of those ideas too for the
amphibians the birds of the mammals
around you and some of what I'm be
talking about the next 58 minutes or so
will be about how we can do better than
that how we can extend that to other
species groups how we can attach a
probabilistic estimate to this and how
can we get it to finer grain size the 50
kilometer radius is of course really
large you'll have many species in that
list that won't be right around you and
with some modeling approaches will like
to take it to a kilometer resolution
with an uncertainty around that estimate
and that's what I like to focus on a
little bit in the final parts of my talk
just showed you that species list tool
that's one of several tools we'd like to
develop and launch over the next year or
two years another application will be
arranged refinement an analysis of the
predicted area network so immediately if
you have this species information you
can actually apply you can use a reserve
as a cookie cutter and get information
okay but which pieces are actually in
that reserve and you can with that
understand quantitatively the coverage
of the reserve network we can do
biodiversity change protection and also
change monitoring and the whole idea is
that we're not doing that one of
analysis we're not writing one paper and
then sort of leave it there and because
as shown earlier said a couple of years
and stuff is already outdated because
there's better data coming available
there is new reserves arising or there
is climate changing so this needs to be
dynamic here the Torico our club storica
a very enigmatic group of species by the
way I'm not going to go into that this
is our expert knowledge about the
species so if you've seen some of those
richness maps earlier that's the sort of
data those would be based on right and
if you zoom in this is I mean it's great
we have that information but it's not
that detailed right this is for
conservation this is limited it's a
blow-up in East Africa we can't conserve
all of East Africa clearly but we know
more about that species we know it's
restricted to about 4,500 meters and
you'd be surprised about how many
species do they have that sort of
knowledge even for many butterflies for
frogs for mammals and its data we can
sort of pull in down the road especially
through the web we also know it's a
forest pieces and that's something
that's often very clear something and
open habitats or a forest species so we
can do better here thanks to the land
cover information that I showed you
earlier we can identify at one
kilometers grain size or even finer
which of the pixels would actually be
suitable within that blob within where
we know that species is which pixels and
one kilometers grain are actually
suitable for that species and it's
actually only these right suddenly we
get a very different impression of of
the distribution of that species and we
can look a little closer and so these
are the forests around Kilimanjaro here
is Mount maro etc and suddenly be going
from a global range of two hundred and
thirty thousand square kilometers to
just 23 thousand kilometres less than
ten percent and of course we'd be having
looking at a very different niche here
compared to their right if we were to do
global change model we skip that now we
can take it a step further and now
overlay that with with the
serve network in the region so these are
not i just made those reserves up just
but just to show you the general idea
and we can actually especially with more
sophisticated modeling that i don't have
the time to get into integrating these
different data sources we can get a
probabilistic estimate so how probable
is it that a species would actually be
within those reserve boundaries and here
well pretty likely here not so likely up
here pretty much no probability right so
to assess reserve effectiveness and
coverage become just overlay these blobs
with our reserve network we actually
have to really try and get things to a
much much finer detail we can do change
projection and apply models as to how
species and vegetation will move up in
the future as the region warms and you
suddenly see that the suitable area
becomes even smaller in the range will
decrease dramatically and we did an
analysis globally actually where we did
that for all montagne bird species that
exactly did that sort of thing for a
thousand bird species worldwide and it
was a very quiet day clearly in the
world but somehow made it onto the front
page here and we we find that a dramatic
loss of range size across all sorts of
species worldwide in these high
elevation habitats and something we can
do the quantitative very rigorous way
thanks to this detailed modeling and we
can combine that thing of course with
the change projection and the reserve
analysis finally we can do change
monitoring looking at here before the
Western fence lizard an extremely rich
record of point data we can split that
into phase period one the 70s and more
recent period to the 90s and then look
at how the niches and the ranges of a
species like that have shifted between
the periods I'm going to spare you the
details here but essentially there are
various scenarios has the range shifted
or not has climate shifted or not and
all sorts of different things may arise
and how does that all sit in relation to
where the reserve is sitting spatially
and then environmentally so to conclude
I hope I've laid out a somewhat at least
convincing vision that we
really need to bring data together we
need to expose it we need to do this in
a dynamic setting online for others to
interact we need to incentivize this we
need to make visually interesting but
also scientifically sound tools that
people like to play with and that
incentivize scientists to provider data
and collaborate and then I think we can
take a really large step over the next
years to get an increasingly stronger
spatial biodiversity knowledge that will
be increasingly more useful for
quantitative conservation prioritization
and also for more rigorous science let
me just conclude that I think the
greatest challenge in all of this is
actually not technically realizing this
vision so we are able to do amazing
things technically now the Big Data
technologies that are coming online the
visual technologies that are coming
online that's not holding us back I
think what the real challenge here is
that we need to overcome is to even just
address this one area just getting the
spatial by Torres design data right the
real challenge here is sociological
rather than technological thank
time for a couple of questions so maybe
this is relevant to your last point of
the sociological challenges is how what
kind of infrastructure are you guys
developing in order to get more field
data set to fill in those gaps and the
highly diverse tropical regions where
you're only relying on these experts
that are really yeah now there's always
contributions from scientists or Natural
History travelers actually I think are
absolutely highly valuable and important
in fact we're trying to incentivize some
of such submissions and I'm going to go
into the detail how we want to bring
them into the system in a moment but the
one way to incentivize is actually to
quantify how valuable such data actually
is so it's so much more valuable to
contribute a data point in central
brazil or or central indonesia than it
is to contribute another bird red
cardinal data point for the Novem for
north america right and they're actually
quantitative ways in which you could
perhaps set this up and and then really
but I have people something they can
talk about or measure hey this is
actually has this sort of value of
contribution that I made here now there
are ongoing citizen science efforts some
of which have been talked about earlier
EB reasoning famous one for birds and
there's some other ones around the world
for specific groups and what we're
trying to do right now is reach out I
mean there are hundreds of such efforts
actually reach out and connect with them
and see whether we can dynamically
connect them in so that their data
immediately flows into this larger
system and can be used for for
additional modeling but we also want to
facilitate the direct upload of data and
make it as easy as possible for people
to do and incentivize through those
tools for sort of value badges as I just
mentioned and through working with
specific communities sort of nerd
communities are excited about their
groups of species and then get into
competition I think there's a real
opportunity here to get similar things
going as ebert has four other tax sites
not necessarily us doing
that may not be a map of life's job but
at least we want to provide
infrastructure to make it easier for
such groups to develop an and pull
together if you will Alison there are
really challenging fallen sociological
issues here as this information gets
more granular and as it is democratized
take for example elephants or Tigers are
you it becomes a very easy way for
purchase to find them big heads are
until we're hug them in it's also a good
guys out there so how do you how do you
think about that now that's very good
point well at this point we're going at
most to a kilometer grain size and it
will be probabilistic but that may be
enough for some species of course to
sort of home in and there it means it's
not just L bits or kids right and egg
hunters other parrots so yes and we've
already I've already gotten some you'd
be surprised lots of emails I've got
enough people like oh can we have this
data and then sort of you look closer
and some commercial parrot operation and
yes it is a problem but it's something
that can be addressed right so you can
certain species you can have a list of
black list of species where you only
officer more detail if people are
accredited with the university or in
some way I think their ways to address
that but it's going to take some work to
be careful here protect me show how do
you mean is this mother's life connected
off in that magical way yeah that's the
whole and the plan now we're working i
hadn't didn't have time to talk about
this we have this project in East Africa
that we've chatted a little bit about
right where we're trying to get take
this to the region so how does this sort
of data compilation in practice work and
benefit conservation again in the region
as we go into more detail and there are
great community-based conservation
efforts in the region and the hope here
is that we will have this this we have
prosumers people that are consuming some
of this understand better
even sort of the distribution of certain
predators vs. their livestock or whatnot
or changes that may happen on the
climate change and with that at same
time incentivize folks to upload and
everybody in East Africa is a cell phone
that's why we need this sort of cell
phone app that allows people to easily
see okay what are the species around me
and I hope through actually mostly that
educational aspect of that that school
children will be able to walk around
with their $10 cell phone and get a
species list on their cell phone where
they are and that a cool teacher is able
to use that yeah to do natural history
education I think that's just extremely
empowering and I've already helped
educate the young people to then address
some of those those issues that
dimension slightly do this
is a platformer
no I didn't there this one the one about
the hierarchical models everyone I did
good explain what so the way that
without water in the back there he's
been developing this and we've been
showing up trying to move this forward
so the general ideas and i'll have to
keep this very brief is that we have
some data that a curated coarse grains
and other sets a curated fine grains and
the challenge is how do you bring those
two different data types these different
scales together right and then we have
environmental data at the fine scales
and there are some really neat
statistical approaches that are
computationally very intense but really
promising that allow you to bring this
data together let the fine-scale
environmental data inform the coarse
grain range data and as long as you even
have enough of that coarse-grained data
you're actually able to get something
out of it and the fine grain if you just
take the right approaches and what you
get with statistic with patient
approaches is you're not only getting a
median predicted probability of a
species occurring so here for this free
toad woodpecker but you also get an
uncertainty estimate around that
probability right so with two percent so
this is these are the areas where
definitely definitely will we'll have
that species now these are the areas
where we are less certain that the
species is and this is the median
prediction so there's a probability as
well as an uncertainty around that
probability estimates so scientifically
much more rigorous way of of estimating
species or currents that's especially
important as you try to overlay it with
a reserve network to really then get to
a statistically sound estimate with
which probability is that specie is
covered by this reserve and what is my
confidence in that in that knowledge
right how can certain cannot really be
that the species is is predicted so
that's what this modeling approach is
trying to do